this is our real thought on the
neverending story movies that you know
all of this is just gonna be talking
about the first one I know people want
us to talk about the third one but it's
like I just want the first one so much
like I just want glorify the hell up
it's gonna be like that damn blue one
all over again what makes my fun okay
that kids really bad that's the one
thing in the movie that's really bad is
that kids not a very good actor you know
what Reeves not that bad I don't know
what your problem yeah yeah that hack uh
know that there bear both know and try
use by just the make it reading the
story uh I so I'll just put it out there
right now I have not read the book and I
don't know what the original cut was
supposed to be apparently there was a
lot more of like Atreyu traveling
through Fantasia which makes sense
because it's kind of like he starts his
quest chores all on Fantasia with these
you know helicopter shots of him riding
and then I defy anything well that's the
thing this is in my mind is uh watching
it again after not seeing it for years I
was like why I forgot how fast this
story is cuz yeah he's never ending
story it's a very quick story you just
takes off from the ivory tower and next
thing you know our tax is dead and I'm
like holy shit I was like that's right
like nothing really happened in between
those two points yeah uh well you see
all these cool characters and these
phenomenal designs at this tower and
yeah watching it again as an adult and
kind of like you know I really want to
know more about these worlds and those
characters and stuff and maybe the inks
tended cut you did the story goes that
it was like some sort of European or
German American Australian Japanese
French Swahili co-production um and
there's a version of the trailer where
the books in German there is a version
of the DIF you actually I think all the
versions of the trailer of the original
trailer if you look at the book closely
uh TN Devon is only there's a
in the king book an or something like a
like you I was just like what the hell
um but yeah that was I guess from the
German version and a I the Ruhr I've
heard is that the German version is like
20 minutes longer and I'm like well yeah
that probably would explain a few things
I really want to see that version I
I love the neverending story but at the
same time I'm like wow isn't it all I'm
like this movie really just flies by
well that first uh like I said from him
taking off from the ivory tower up to
the swamp ass and it's like yeah that
goes really fast everything else I think
is perfectly paced I think it goes in a
really nice uh you know I have sort of
this nice toned ass or gets more and
more dark and depressing and stuff no no
no it does it just a but you're right no
it rare it's like we complain about how
long movies are nowadays here's a rare
one where I'm just like man I want this
movie to be longer well you know the
funny thing again sort of a tribute to
to the kid that played a tray you uh
where the horse is dying it's like we
barely got to see him with that horse
but by god you felt that friendship just
through that perfect ah it's completely
true and then it's like as a kid that
was so heartbreaking as the doll but I'm
just like what the fuck oh yeah like how
does the horse get dip fries or was it
not yes oh but they make fun visit my
table alone Sam got to put the Prozac
and the carrot like I don't
yeah I don't get I just don't get it I'm
just like well maybe it's a commentary
that like a animals have feelings and
stuff I mean you know which is you know
true I mean animals are emotional too
you know but yeah it is good alright
just out of nowhere it's like oh um okay
I guess the horse will never take a
depressed horse into the swamps to
sadness um
I know there's anything to take from the
story um
but man the uh there is that you know
again what I love about this movie this
fantasy is I get like all really great
fantasies are just stories that want to
establish an environment it lets you
live in that environment for a Bedan
little I believe their place was we ya
know and when he's with those little
gnomes and and the giant turtle and
stuff like that like nothing's going on
you're just sitting there and you're
talking but you just love these people
and then glaze over yeah the stupid bad
yeah I need all those characters I think
that the characters are so well defined
and so well acted uh that the
environment which you know it is still
good environment but while they're just
talking there's not that much to look at
uh you just feel like it's a real place
and these characters are real characters
and it allows you those moments it isn't
just hey we have to go into this thing
now it's going to this thing now that
was like almost the trap that lor the
Rings fell into that I thought it it
like as we went on they got no no as
they went on but now today that oh
fellowship sucks
no no then we got the Hobbit movies that
went the exact opposite direction where
it's like okay we can we can lead your
own who claim that first Hobbit film was
the Fellowship of the Ring movie you
wanted it is I like the first one but ya
know as they went out of my okay it
feels like home working out um but yes
it was home it's like I still never
solved the third one uh there's like
school can you make it to the end of it
yeah ideas just say it's like learning a
history lesson it's like you're missing
the the fun and the character and
whatever I shouldn't judge haven't seen
the third the practical effects uh yeah
art Antarctic um Falkor Israel well
they're all really there you know that
there's some effects because sort of
roll your eyes like way he's supposed to
be flying
Falkor and clearly it's just a blue
screen it's he's very obvious shot you
know whatever but at least
Falkor the most important thing about it
is really their yeah all the ground
shots when he's talking to a tray you I
still look at that like wow yeah I mean
that's cool I don't know we're with how
he owes CGI'd some thing I'll say this
you know and see cuz everyone always
likes to get out and be like you know
you're
too hard on CGI and stuff like that CGI
has done unbelievable stuff stuff I came
in comprehend how they do I just watch
fucking two towers again Gollum still
fucking looks like he's right there yeah
if we think I'm looking that good but I
don't always look like going for the
most part that's very rare
yeah like they put all of their effort
into it that's why it looked like that
and when I see even today when I see
Falkor they're you know talking to it's
like it's fucking impressive years later
that's still fucking impressive where I
think with a lot of CG we look back here
as late as like and it's dated yeah
that's not looking so good where we can
look at all this stuff in the past that
was really there I mean got all that's
on the screen you just watch my movie
that we're gonna review for nostalgia
Queen and the CGI was pretty bad wait
nineties and really bad yeah it was a
mix of like practical and CGI but the
CGI a knockout is yeah they they were
just like okay and just they didn't mix
them at all that just like anthro CGI
they're throw it there and it's white
it's you they'll buy it yeah um but but
yeah and I think they're great thing
about the movie is that I don't know it
on top of the pacing on top of the
environment on top of these great
characters on top of it being a really
neat idea and original you know that
this world is original these creatures
are original uh I found it a bit
challenging to as a kid but I liked it
it wasn't something I watched alike
well I kill the horse for one thing they
fucking kill everybody yeah fuckin
middle of the movie sets up the town
where it's like hey this best friend of
a través god it's not just the fact that
he died it's that slow quicksand dad and
you're just like when it's just the head
sticking out as a child I was just like
oh my god what and what and what they
did that made that even stronger is that
the kid kind of goes through the stages
the seven stages of yeah yeah you know
even doubt this like you're you dislike
this like the denial the anger the
bargaining but you kind of would - and
it's totally relatable I'm even wheeze
yelling at the horse you just you get
it's like what do you want to die come
on you stupid Dalek don't be
um but yet not just the dark stuff but
even sort of that challenge of this
existential you know journey that's
going on between the kid reading the
book and the book being alive and
there's been stories where somebody's
like just read a book or watch the show
and it's like no no it's real or there's
like a character at the end winking or
something there they pull them into the
book or the story by here I need this
felt like whoa is this are they fucking
watching here something like there is
this kind of creep value away it's like
the way she says it to and they've all
been watching his adventures like he's
been reading yours a try you others have
been watching his and you're just like
are they talking about me like this shit
just got meta yeah I mean it's one of
those things where it's just like what
the wait I mean you know it's a movie
and everything but it's like what where
are they going with this and they don't
quite touch I they don't go any further
but it's like just that little than we
watching his adventures all think the
same thing which is what kind of a
fucking name is moon job.but moon child
is way sure you're not supposed to hear
the day but yes that is what they
clarify he shot which okay no here's the
thing you want time enough but there's
gonna be somebody out there's like my
mother's name wasn't if he if he
actually like made up that name for the
childlike Empress that's a really good
name for somebody called the childlike
Empress that is a perfect name moon
child but it's his mother's name what
fucking hippie was called muchacha he
must have been a celebrity she must have
been a celebrity skin today no the only
thing I think you to the Father is much
more you know the down-to-earth keep
your fee planned and stuff like that and
again Vasia Dabney Coleman thing going
on the first yeah I love it um and uh
you can tell if the lover's name was
fucking moon child you can tell she was
the one that had all the dreams the
imagination stuff like that and
therefore he's obviously holding up I
didn't read the book so I should
probably just read the damn book
apparently the book sounds actually
really fascinating I should read it
oh why no in the case of the movies I
guess the second movie is the second
part of the book well no even though
Leonard has elements as I leave it or
not of the book um you know not much
innocence destroyed but even the
elements where they are still there so
yeah I thought I thought the first film
was so well done and again a children's
film done like an adult film like done
with the same amount of effort and
pacing and care that you would put into
an adult film
what's cool by the way is he fuckin
Hogwarts because that attic is like
something out of Hogwarts it's like ha
ha yes let's sneak up to the Attic with
all of a creepy weird scary props and
the the do not break glass that's broken
and he just sneaks in the schools a
lawsuit waiting down it's an agent who
just stays up there for a second I don't
know what of how we got out of the 80s
you and I should be dead when I look at
the way jr. is nowadays well make
something we see our children spells it
so that the widow is a dark creepy place
you'd be scared motherfucker I was like
I'm watching like some commercial and
it's got this like little kid growing up
in a car seat and it severed self like
baby then she's a toddler and then she's
like this really little girl but I swear
to God the last shot she's like an eight
year old grown 8 year old girl like
partying in the car seat and I'm like
what what what happened to hear my
wife's tell me oh yeah no it's like now
it's like base by weight and you can get
a ticket if your child isn't in the car
suppose look you could be like eight
years old in a car see look how did we
live should be dead we didn't wear
helmets are do anything yeah nah it was
maybe we were lucky maybe everyone else
got weeded out ha ha ha ha we can't be
survival by the fitness we can't be what
survive the survival we're not to finish
no no we are no where it's at to tell
our the unlock we are the god is just
like hey you wanna see me have two
assholes live just out here Lagos choose
those two there we go ha ha hello fuck
with religion so um yeah first of all I
think it's just wonderful um I think
it's so well done second film is atcha
what got me to the first phone cuz I
they were advertising it in theaters I
was like but never these story to I'm
like we will never know why you saw
these films in
actually we saw the second one first in
theaters no no I think I ice at least I
did I saw the first one to prepare
myself for the second one because the
second one looks like fun and look cool
i all i need let me be this way all if
they worry about disney channel cuz yeah
I lose it all they read it with the
nipples of Statue nipples uh old school
Disney it's dark gritty ohter means um
hella Fantasia you see you see nipples
in - yeah but you don't see blackface
Centaurs then look it up it is oh my god
um anywho
don't blame me that's Disney no no
that's it big does that it was real it
was real look it up um we saw okay so
yeah all I remember is we saw them
around the same time yeah yeah they're
very short long it did see we did see it
shortly before cuz yeah they were
plugging neverending story to left last
what they used to do I mean before
gremlins - they ran the frit that's how
I always saw these films I never saw
before is that the sequel was coming out
and then they ran the original on TV
same thing with currently I saw the
first gremlins cuz gremlins - was coming
out uh so so I saw this element as a kid
I didn't hate it or dislike it or
anything I just was bored I could just
kind of feel like this somehow the first
one was better and I couldn't connect
why um I still liked that they were
there was a lot of imagination there's a
lot of practical effects and stuff
that's really didn't I wish to this I
it's felt the movie felt a little
different I still felt somehow we were
in the same universe yeah did not get
that at a movie 3 no um we'll get to
that but but like even when you see that
city cuz he's floating on this water in
the say assign the water it's like acid
or something like that and you know it's
like that just that sounds right it's
this beautiful city but it's like
there's still something that's like no
there's something deadly here still it's
like really fungi create the world at
the end of neverending story 100 that
come out of his head he's like you know
I see link of acid let's make this app
it's all so big you know it's like did
others head okay the world was the story
kind of living without it but that again
that's why I like about is maybe again I
should read the books one a few times
where the baby it was kind of little
because imagination stuff is just such
an abstract concept it's like the idea
of how the technicals work is kind of
vague well and I know so I don't get too
hard on to tell women this could happen
how could this have that to me was the
coolest scene out of the four - it's
just the one grain yeah left and I'm
like whoa and like it's a very silent
kind of yeah get out at the realtor and
they lead up to with the the freaking
wolf that way like I want that in
another movie somewhere where he's
watching his adventures in my idea and
then the final one is the wolf it's like
ha and there it is yeah I mean what a
great bill and what a great job that
woman any better but Rhonda gets a
little I mean it's like it's a little
silly and the mouth movies don't quite
imagine stuff but it's like the shadow
and the atmosphere and the voice and
stuff like it works I serve nothing yeah
I mean the creepier things like the only
one that could stop me I lost him in the
swamp of despair I don't know where you
went and you're just like shit shit shit
shit fuck oh fuck yeah that wolf was
scary as fuck but ok goes out like a
bitch oh yeah what the hell he just like
jumps on him and he's like oh you had
some sharp piece of pottery
woe is me what what after all that
buildup meanwhile the nothing's like man
I so what you do you chased after him
missed him it was right in front of you
you didn't get him and then when you did
figure out was him
you jumped on them and went out in like
two seconds you know not a very good
henchman uh come on
I am literally quite literally nothing
and I'm doing more than you and I better
yeah yeah oh but says he had the second
film uh and yeah again I I kind of like
the idea of him going into the world and
even idea of kind of making the wishes
though I think if they're gonna do that
thing good idea if you're gonna but I
felt like somehow something just in
click it's one of those movies where
you're just like I'm paper this looks
kind of cool like oh and the memories
represent things oh it's a giant
metaphor for this
is an evil kind of white witch kind of
Queen I'm like it kind of all looked
good on paper but somehow when you put
it all together I just remember I just
remember sitting there even as a kid
like 10 11 years old or something just
bore like I just kind of sat there just
like yeah you know and it was feel like
I didn't hate it but it was just awkward
I think it's the best way to describe it
is that it's an awkward sequel that has
some good ideas but the performance is a
little off the ideas are not quite fully
fleshed out or explained that grade
again they start trying to start they
try to put rules to it which is okay if
you can balance it out can with the
imagination stuff and the whole thing
with the wishing because I made a big
deal about if this kid can fucking wish
for anything
why doesn't he wish for like all these
problems go away and stuff if they
emphasize that it's to make there to be
small wishes because they had to keep
the story interested that like he's kind
of the storyteller while he's also in
the story that's a fascinating idea but
they never go into them they never
explained they never really has an
abandonment I know but people I know
read the book like the books generally
better yeah I mean in the book
if I'm right I think like bash and get
sucked into the world and then he gets
like a little too addicted he almost
becomes like a dictator
yeah that's what I heard like that
sounds intriguing yeah I would have been
I kind of would have been all over that
yeah like they were going there ever so
slightly when he just starts becoming a
dick in the second film but I once again
it never felt like it went anywhere
whether it was like oh and I was gonna
become a dick I know him in a tre you
were gonna fight and be some of the
super foul core just takes up with the
tre you like her
oh fuck you well and and like I said I
mean some parts where it gets a little
too literal and I don't I know that's
ironic me saying that because like at
the end the first one he's literally
flying Falkor in the real world and
stuff but even then how much of it and
I'm not FEA better they actually were he
chases the bullies I just roll my eyes a
little bit like Kay don't know you don't
get it it's a sweet story about using
imagination to achieve your long sought
revenge
- smoked your enemies um or smile a
smile I don't know but but I like to
think he just has like a 105 degree
fever and is will be passed out in that
attic dreaming man that policeman or you
could also argue honestly that it's in
the story you could kinda argue that you
don't quite know cuz it kind of just
stops abruptly
um but yeah and with the second one
you're starting to handle words like the
books are literally disappearing in the
real world or at least the book story is
and it's kind of like well as he was he
mythical the book store owner or
whatever it's like I don't know there's
some questions like I both do want to
ask those questions and I don't I feel
like just going into some play something
books yeah I felt like he should have
been in the real world who like knew
about this world imagine that fucking
dude nowadays with everybody staring at
their phones he could just be certainly
conduit say like the whole time just
like yo give me a radius and give me a
ride I one more text and I'd like to
think the poor bookkeeper would have
died off by then because like he would
be so miserable now he's like ah cheaper
worse reading the books on our phones
phones we have kid those Kindles sound
like a gameboy
not even don't look at him some ways
imprinted on dead trees no that is not a
book makes no sense so impractical um
I'll say that would be inter cuz reading
is a really big gonna mail honestly
freaking Christopher Lloyd from
pagemaster look like a Girl Scout but uh
yeah I wasn't gonna say um so yeah so
you have the second film that has some
good ideas but like I said I think it's
just kind of awkward everything about it
just feels a little awkward it's a Miss
execution I don't want it like I did
some god-awful no no like there are way
worse kids films out there but it's
definitely it is what the word mad
wasn't bad because it is it has not got
off what's not like oh this is the worst
thing I've ever seen but isn't by no
stretch of the imagination really good
so it is just a straight flat
middle-of-the-road man movie you watch
it is coming
yeah oh and then we got our third film
our little treasure fuck
we're just like I don't know I felt like
this is what in Iron Man 3 when they had
what was it the Mandarin and it's like
you have this character that's like you
know in the lore of this complex and
it's just like okay we're just gonna do
everything we can to fuck this character
in the ass and that's like what they do
with is thank God I never liked Mandarin
as a character to begin I would so pay
yeah I didn't know anything about
manager but Donna's you're like oh wow
no I know I think there's a better
example here I I think gems gonna be the
new neverending story three I think
that's gonna be the words like I did you
take something that we kind of enjoyed
it but just shit
yes sure I I didn't even watch him
growing up and I've insulted for Jen
Fanning like you deserve better
that's not a gym I was not a gym person
um be a tease or a different time you
could get beat up for liking something
like that even that it was I remember
the song that was about it I'd even know
what the plot really was but even even
me not knowing the flattery thing I saw
the trailer I'm like that's not Jam I
just didn't really want I saw a handful
of episodes no barely anything about it
and I had the same reaction was watching
a termite
I'm completely insulted not this show um
so so we have that equivalent for a
neverending story three yeah um which I
will say just for kind of the insanity
of it it almost works on a Batman Robin
level like I'm gonna say oh my goodness
Sheree I'm gonna say this out loud I
would get shit now fuck it fuck it i'ma
say it I actually do it well I actually
drew watching this movie better I do
neverending story too I am excited
I'm not saying objectively that it is a
better movie reel better made oh me
or ever was put in or anything like that
so fucking bad that it's it's like
watching a train wreck yeah it's a you
know what it is it's like watching a
train speed past you really fast or
watching an actual train wreck then
running story 2 is just a train passing
nefertiti is the train wrecking
exploding and then Godzilla comes in and
takes a giant shit on that just for fun
ya know it's like the first neverending
story is getting on this magical train
like the Polar Express or the one from
spirited away it takes you on a magical
the next one's just you're missing a
train you missed it
it's like oh dang it there go oh it's
Metra and maybe that's and and then the
third one is like you got on the train
and it just crashed in this like Silver
Streak total explosion mind fuck oh my
god mrs. social over the walls yeah I
mean just like and it's just it's so
horrible to watch but you can't look
away and I think if we're going to give
credit where credit is due and where the
biggest train wreck is we got to go to
jet black yeah whoo
thank you yes just thank you for Jack
Black in that pink yah
he is thank you so much hi uh he saved
this movie from completely being well he
saved it from being neverending story -
that's the thing it like this if you
took out the the stupid rockbiter baby
the stupid rock bite Arab and Jack Black
if you took those three things out this
would have been just like neverending
story to me I would have been like oh
yeah not as good as they're running
story - probably worse but you just
would have been like at but you put
those three things in it and it's it's
like the Vanilla Ice movie it's just oh
the cheese yeah you just you can't fuck
with you watch your watch I still can't
believe it I still think when I think
back on that movie that I made it up in
my own head I'm like no no they were
they were rapping no that didn't happen
though the rock fighter did not have a
baby that doesn't know
know that the baby is in the second one
but he'll that's right born wild singing
horn him that's the dinosaur
sitcom-style house with the whole
domestic end the the rockbiter wife like
yeah the hell I could Jamaican accent or
something I can't remember what it was
it was getting dangerously charged our
ask for be idolized it was so sir on the
bottom go on you should make a miss mind
you submit I'm with what is though I
don't remember what the ex I just Mary
was not here I couldn't get what they
were doing well you probably sounded
normal we've probably made this up in
our own a sound worse yeah
because every memory I have of this one
was probably even worse than it was
I probably John it's probably very
accurate maybe I've watch it again now
and be like okay this is just bad I just
want to hate it more I just every time I
think about this movie like I'm just
like holy shit was that like were we on
drugs the born to be why I mean all the
earth stuff like you said is bad but the
born to be wild bit is just like wet I
mean out of what stretch of the
imagination would you think any of this
would go together him driving this and
singing born to be why why would he sing
it you know what it is a wild it's why
that song it's Italian Titanic worthy
yeah I think that's when I watch is I'm
like okay grandpa were same people who
made the Italian Titanic obviously had a
hand in this mmm why it feels like I
know they didn't but it feels like it
it's like this is the same sort of crazy
mindset of like just throw whatever you
can at the wall crap out of script we
know what's really painful too honestly
is that looking at the actors uh in this
the performers if I correct
all of these actors and performers have
done good stuff before I mean it Jack
like as much as we like to make fun of
me he's good he's funny I mean he could
be very entertaining the kid I know it
sounds weird but from Free Willy he was
good and Free Willy I mean the movies
corny and silly but he was good free
football right from black
Willie for the acting is actually way
better than any right today like Free
Willy has a movie at the time I thought
was actually better than it probably had
any right to be like we make fun of it
but yeah I thought it was maybe a lil we
got awful mime look this is just kind of
cheesy yeah uh you know Baldrick from
Blackadder is in it uh what's her name
for children isn't like someone from
children doing it they are the one that
played the empress or something oh oh
yeah the the TV minis yeah I'm yes I
think these are good at a former in this
movie but she was in a lot of schlock
though she was a lot of sci-fi movies of
the week guy thing but but but it's like
oh it's like these are and then the Jim
Henson Company coming in so yeah a
practical effects and deja I'm sure they
just didn't have the budget or they
slashed or something so movies you feel
get destroyed from the bottom up like
the actors aren't any good there's no
chemistry nothing's clicking this one I
felt was that we destroyed from the top
down I'm like all your pieces are in
place this should work but some of the
up top just like okay as I said just put
out at it very much yeah um so complete
total insult do everything neverending
story stands for and for that reason I
find it more entertaining to watch it ya
know I totally know you're talking about
it really is got the Batman Robin almost
afraid ever any it is a room of
children's fantasy what the fuck was
going on here um no I'm kinda with you
it is so strange I mean it it is such an
insult but it is so strange it's such a
bizarre insult uh and you just sort of
like it's like so wait if some of the
come up to you and say you're a
woodchuck banana I mean well that's
clearly an insult but what you might
have ever wind it again to hear it and
listen to it listen to the UH you know
the way they said it in the way the oh
yeah how did what what and the Easter
calf laughing at this just so stranden
and how is that supposed to work
woodchuck banana I I don't get it I
believe a wind it again limb and you're
just so fascinated by the choice by this
insult and then you come around it's
like you know you're more fascinated by
woodchuck banana than I I am but you
know it was a spur of the moment in so
Kiska I know
have the creativity and mindlessness
that something like neverending story 3
does I can't come up with something that
creatively bad you know and intend for
it to be good so yeah why were they in
our reality again who all of them I
don't know the nasties that's right guys
please oh no that's your thing okay and
then I think that's proof that the
second film had more of an understanding
about the the world and the story even
though it wasn't that good because the
first one is but nothing and then the
second one's the emptiness and it's
Callie yeah that beat that sounds right
that the eyes and the throat the nasties
they're just a bunch of bullies call
that nasty all I can think of his honey
badger just ill that's nasty that's a
nasty don't give a shit oh man she's
doing fuck they want yeah it's just one
of the things where it's like you just
can't grasp it and it's so clearly not
trying to be what the first two films
are uh so yeah but but it's it's so
fascinating it's so intriguing um uh
yeah I will say this like Jack Black's
one of those lucky charms we've had and
some of the films we reviewed where I
feel like the movie is improved by him
being in it yeah that is true those from
bad to laugh out loud bad and then it
sort of goes from like you know then
you'll put up in good movies or
something like that it's just like a
shit he's kind of bringing this down you
know something I need to find you need
to find the middle road yet Jack work is
like a very Hampton or some bikes
you can't ya can't put him in something
really good but you like you don't want
to put him in something bad cuz he's
wasted though he will improve the movie
don't put this up you really good as you
drag it down he's kind of find that just
the road there's a big Biddle Road move
right foodpanda if you want those movies
are really good oh I can't wait for the
third one oh Ken like MSG you don't want
to put it in everything it's like a spy
you don't want put to you
need a little bit of improvement but
you're not gonna put it in a 5-star me
hey um so yeah
there it is I can't think of too much
else to say about these films they try
this they're awesome I mean the first
ones here's what I asked
yeah um and the only thing if you want
something funny again just to see how
it's well if you feel that's
Americanized but it still really works
despite it and I know one of the things
you can tell a deep row in this movie
most of us know what Detroit sounds like
now I mean you spend a lot of films and
stuff like that
you look at his dump in this I mean even
back then it's like you know a deep fry
you don't know he has his very
particular distinct voice and you can
practically hear him in this movie you
know you look at me cuz rockbiter like
that you know that's deep fried but they
dump it you now he sounds like this
rockbiter
and it doesn't go at all it's really
really bad luck buttering rockbiter nice
and that's are the rockbiter what you
told us is also true in the north and
it's like why then they keep his voice I
mean about what are you look so cool the
top end and everything is why didn't
they keep that voice um but anywho
that's that's the movie it's still still
old stuff still it's great love watching
you love introducing people to it uh you
know there's a lot of people who have
seen it all there's people and kids
growing up and stuff like that I mean it
is an older film so I run with kids
today without up but that it's a great
feeling introduced I love watching their
reactions because they're not like haha
this is awesome they're just the kind of
noisy mess right now
it's a mesmerizing love that I love when
they watch something and it's something
kind of new and challenging they don't
know how to accept it even when they're
done well that's good what that is
something like sitting with them that's
something I miss I feel was very big in
the 80s and even some of the sudden walk
out kids felled me you don't know how
yours yeah yeah you don't know how
you're supposed to feel and you watch
and it's not always about this is
awesome you're just kind of hypnotized
by yeah just like okay and I don't I
don't feel like I get that out of most
kids films nowadays there's a few
kamo yarn wah oh yeah no I get it more
from kids TV now yeah that's true like
kids TV to me is emulating more of what
we had in the eighties I don't get out
of kids movies that you go to well kids
combs now I mean let's be are for the
most part very good but you're right
there is this very understandable there
is this very room entertain the hell of
you make you feel like you want this
rollercoaster ride while also having it
be really medium really good and story
driven and character driven but you're
right that sort of strange hypnotism we
don't sort of allow that much of anymore
yes or than be as a key film ish got a
feeling of a mystery yeah like you just
you serve like because you want people
to walk it was great I want go see it
again fair enough mandy-rae always
slightly uncomfortable it's like a
slightly uncomfortable mystery where
it's like I don't know whether to be
scared or not this is all just weird
yeah like and I feel like the 80s really
captured that with some of those movies
and you're just like I I have no idea
like you're kind of scared yeah you kind
of want to watch you can and now I mean
they're not bad but know that you very
very good a lot of films nowadays they
are just just about just well entertain
you entertain you yeah and how how can
we make this as big awesome and exciting
as possible and you'll be like why is
that bad it's like it's not but the
variety of these other films that are
like we want to try something a little
different and like it says sort of
create this world he can just sort of
live in and feel comfortable in or
uncomfortable in uh you know and
challenge you a little bit without kind
of punching you in the face with
something uh should be welcomed as well
um but yeah so there it is uh first
films great so I can film a third film a
magnificent trainwreck of a masterpiece
a masterpiece and yes we're done and
what else probably say but um which at
banana neverending story
oh I made a woman a song then I remember
not only there I haven't heard the song
in forever all I know is never-ending
school hurry
Oh try